I always say that I you know people
don't believe me but I always say that
you know I'm uh I'm uh I'm a progressive
on these issues so I I mean more it's
the regulatory issue and I've written
two books on how it could be done but I
mean over the years I mean I guess
disappointment after disappointment
makes you worry that they won't be able
to get their act together even in a
perfect world in those months when you
watch Trump in the press conferences you
may have felt more uncertain and more
nervous because he discussed it so
flippantly uh covet's no big deal just
maybe some maybe bleach will help I
don't know maybe bleach will help maybe
light will help I mean he's speculating
in front of national audience uh and so
of course that's going to be unnerving
when people are seeing casualties and
hospitals overwhelmed he doesn't give
you the feeling of somebody who's
following all the details and and and
you do worry that he had uh secondary
motives which is obviously he was facing
a re-election I think the combination of
the most divisive president in human
history a election year and uh I I think
that's a recipe for a disaster but the
reason I I pretty particularly puts
maybe more blame on fauci is you know
presumably he defines himself he's the
adult in the room and yet he didn't want
to have debates I mean look at how they
demonized Jay and Martin uh he quelched
opposition he put out his own statements
that DeSantis reopened schools in the
spring of 2020 that was the right
decision but he opposed those and so I
mean I expect more from people who are
the adults in the room for me it's an
obvious point that when you're facing a
situation you've never faced before and
making decisions that are larger than
have ever been made in human history and
unprecedented that that's an opportunity
where smart people will have the most
disagreement not the least disagreement
it's the least settled and I think what
you need is and I suspect maybe this
applies to war too I mean if I had a
bunch of generals around a table I want
somebody there to argue why we're not
doing the right thing so I can hear the
counter arguments and think about it and
even if I do what I'm going to do anyway
I do it knowing some things that I might
have been blind to
um I think Scalia famously used to have
a clerk whose only job was they
disagreed with him but they provided a
balance in science it's so desperately
necessary I I think that to me the
failure of scientific debate has been
the greatest failure around the pandemic
podcasts this this video that you're all
doing you we all did a better job than
universities I mean Stanford Harvard my
own institution I can't think of a
single debate we've had on visitor
policies masking in the hospital School
closure
um masking in communities vaccine uptake
in policies we've had zero debates I'm
in the department of epidemiology who
should be debating this if not the
universities and why are universities
not debating that I think that's part of
a broader Trend where ideas that people
disagree with are viewed as violence and
not something to contend with and outwit
and and persuade and I think that's a
huge problem
um so you had fauci and uh and Collins
they had a point of view a policy they
wanted to advance uh debate would
threaten to reveal their errors and they
chose to quelch debate I want to point
out one more thing they're in a unique
role they're both somebody who's a
pundit on TV telling you what we should
do with schools and they're the head of
the agency that gives scientists their
funding right our funding is dependent
on their institution and so any
scientist who may feel like they
disagree has to weigh the professional
repercussions that they at least believe
could happen in their mind and I think
in the future no one should hold both
those jobs if you want to be a pundit be
a pundit but don't control denyad budget
but it's structural and systemic uh it
if it wasn't fouchy if it wasn't Francis
Collins you know it it's likely we would
have still had similar mistakes made
because when you have centralized
control and centralized power and
centralized knowledge you know the the
possibility of COG you know of bias and
uh you know just you know bad decision
making uh being really negative the the
consequence of that are much more likely
I totally agree I mean as much as I do
blame them and I I do blame them at a
personal level and I do think some of
them should be fired um and I've written
that but but I think you're right that
it is a structural problem and you could
have replaced them with other actors who
would have made similar if not worse or
different place yeah we've I mean we've
replaced one president with another and
error continues so right you know meet
the old boss or meet the new boss the
same as the old boss I mean part of my
impression was that one of the saving
Graces here in the United States was the
fact that we do have this Federalist
system where different states could try
different approaches so we had Ron
DeSantis here in Florida trying
something else
um radically different than what
California where I was living at the
time was doing
um and was in contradiction to the guy
the CDC guidance
um and with the vaccine question I I
don't think the census is necessarily
anti-vaccine but he's the Florida's
certainly taking a different approach in
in terms of what it the its state level
agency is recommending for different
ages in terms of the vaccine and so I
just wonder if that given the current
state of the CDC and the FDA if that is
part of the answer is continuing to
devolve power down from them just make
them less powerful give them less
authority to impose mandates you know
issuing guidance or you know keeping
track of Statistics is one thing but you
know imposing any sort of either
mandates or or gatekeeping is where we
really seem to run into problems uh
especially once you get up to the
federal level where you're talking about
330 million people
that's a superb Point
um and I just I mean I totally agree
with you that if you want to strip them
of powers I will support that and I was
the opposite view maybe five years ago
but I just want to point out one way
that kind of backfired was the school
reopening because Biden came into office
and he said he wanted to reopen schools
within 100 days uh and not even high
schools and he had difficulty because a
lot of local typically left of center
jurisdictions decided that they want to
keep them closed for the rest of this
the year despite the fact teachers were
getting the vaccines first and so
decentralized Authority
um can lead to Innovation because I
think Florida did more things right than
California but it can also lead to uh
chaos because I think San Francisco
schools as an unmitigated disaster do
you have a personal politics and um you
know how how does that factor into your
kind of framework and approach to these
types of topics well I'm a lifelong
Democrat I'm a Bernie Sanders supporter
and so to see my side get these issues
steadily incorrect has been catastrophic
I mean we got we're we're the side
that's supposed to say we care about
poor disadvantaged minority children we
did the single greatest discriminatory
action in quarter Century which was
closed their schools for 18 months and
guess what they all got coveted anyway
and guess and most of them got covered
before they got vaccines because uptake
is so poor in that age group because the
data is so weak and so what have we done
we're the group that says we're you know
we believe in scientific principles the
same people who say that are critical of
the Cochrane report on masking because
it didn't yield the conclusion they want
and so I guess covid-19 has been a
profound disappointment uh that my side
has any moral or scientific superiority
over any other side and uh and and now
I'm I'm I'm without a party hey thanks
for watching that excerpt from our
conversation with vinay Prasad about U.S
Public Health mRNA vaccines and future
threats that the president set by covet
emergency measures might pose to our
civil liberties you can check out the
full conversation by clicking on the
link in the description and catch these
conversations streamed live to reason TV
every Thursday at 1 pm Eastern see you
next time